les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de Franz 24 bajo el sol del sur
de Francia comenzó el mayor
acontecimiento cinematográfico del mundo
el festival de Cana un evento que le
hace honor a las películas pero sobre
todo a los actores y actrices que
caminan la mítica alfombra roja del
festival bajo las cámaras de los
fotógrafos y las miradas del público el
día de la apertura fue marcado por la
presencia de la actriz más famosa de
Francia que participó en la ceremonia y
también por el estadounidense Michael
douglass que recibió una palma de oro de
honor por sus 55 años de extraordinaria
trayectoria en el cine pero la mayoría
de las Estrellas de la pantalla grande
vienen acampará a acompañar El
preestreno de sus películas es el caso
del director Martin scorsese y de dos de
sus actores favoritos Robert de Niro y
Leonardo DiCaprio reunidos por primera
de 3 horas y media el otro gran actor
que marcó estos primeros días de
festival y que los fans esperaban ver de
nuevo con su emblemático sombrero y su
látigo Harrison Ford está de vuelta en
la como Indiana Jones a sus 80 años y 40
años después de la última película para
presentar esta vez el quinto y último
episodio de La saga del aventurero
arqueológico la cinta se llama Indiana
[Música]
la película de apertura de esta edición
número 76 del festival de can Marco
también las Mentes
de la directora francesa mayween y
protagonizada por Johnny Depp se trata
de su primer gran papel después del
mediático juicio que llevó con su
expareja que le acusó de maltrato erigir
esta película para abrir el festival es
una decisión que despertó muchas
críticas incluso dentro de la industria
cinematográfica por ejemplo en una
Tribuna más de un centenar de actrices y
actores franceses explican que rechazan
la postura política adoptada por el
festival de Cana y afirman que citó al
extender la alfombra roja a la hombres y
mujeres que agreden el festival envía el
mensaje que en nuestro país podemos
seguir practicando la violencia
impunemente que la violencia es
aceptable en los lugares de creación
estos mismos celebraron el anuncio una
semana antes del festival decana de la
estrella del cine francés Adela que
eligió dejar de actuar para denunciar la
complacencia generalizada de la
profesión hacia los agresores sexuales
una decisión
cuestiona cómo funciona este ámbito
en el contexto de un movimiento social
histórico estamos a la espera de ver si
las eminencias del cine se apoyarán como
los patrocinadores de la Industria Del
lujo en la policía para que todo siga
como siempre las alfombras rojas del
festival de can frente al monopolio de
la palabra y de las finanzas de la
burguesía No tengo más armas que mi
cuerpo y mi integridad cultura de la
anulación en el sentido original ustedes
tienen el dinero el poder y toda la
gloria hacen gárgaras con ello pero no
me tendrán como espectadora les cancelo
de mi mundo volvemos a las
particularidades de esta edición del
festival de Kan para analizar Quién hace
parte de la selección oficial Desde el
miércoles la carrera para ganar la palma
de oro está en marcha por lo que ganes
ante todo Una competencia este año 21
películas se enfrentan en esta categoría
que es la más prestigiosa y si miramos
los directores de las cintas
seleccionadas podemos reconocer sin
dificultad unos nombres el británico Ken
ya fueron galardonados con al menos una
palma de oro durante las presidentes
ediciones de Cana ellos hacen parte del
club de los habituales del festival y
del lado de las directoras siete de las
21 películas a concursos son de mujeres
eso representa un tercio no es paridad
pero ya es un récord en la historia del
festival escuchamos lo que piensa el
delegado general de Cana al respecto
este año hay siete mujeres directoras en
competición es decir más del 30% se dice
que ahora hay un 18% de mujeres
directoras en el mundo Así que estamos
muy por encima obviamente Este es el
récord de Khan pero no quiero decir
necesariamente sí es genial vemos las
películas las vemos hablamos de ellas sé
que
es genial Es que la presencia y la
importancia creciente de las mujeres
directoras en el cine
significa que de manera más evidente que
antes y como en la literatura o la
música La Mirada femenina las historias
femeninas llegarán de otra manera al
mundo del cine
otro nombre que destaca dentro de esta
selección oficial es la directora Franco
senegalesa
y son las dos representantes del
continente africano en la carrera para
la palma de oro pero lo interesante
derramará
es su primer largometraje una historia
de amor rodada en el norte de senegal
miremos el traidor
[Música]
durante todo el festival de canna los
cuatro canales de Franz 24 Están
movilizados para ofrecerles entrevistas
resúmenes de películas y reportajes
nuestra compañera María Carolina piña de
nuestra cadena hermana radio Francia
internacional está presente cada día en
nuestras noticieros pero también en los
programas especiales de Carrusel de las
artes y gracias a nuestros colegas del
canal de francés vamos ahora a echar un
vistazo entre bastidores a este evento
único
[Música]
24 escalones 60 metros de largo la
alfombra roja se ha convertido en uno de
los símbolos del festival de Khan
imprescindible para las estrellas se
encuentra justo debajo del Igualmente
icónico Cartel del festival con motivo
de esta edición La magnífica actriz
francesa en la película
[Música]
en sus más de 70 años de existencia el
festival ha acogido a las mayores
estrellas del cine por supuesto pero
también a los iconos de los años 80 y 90
de Lady diamadona y sus pechos cónicos
imágenes inolvidables también Natalie
portman con la cabeza rapada para la
película V de Vendetta Ryan gosling
besando a su director o quentin
tarantino bailando con Melany y en 2018
82 mujeres del Séptimo arte subieron las
escaleras para reivindicar la igualdad
en el mundo del cine
es en la mítica donde es más probable
ver a una de las estrellas saliendo de
uno de los muchos hoteles de lujo frente
al mar durante 10 días estos Palacios
acogen a grandes marcas y celebridades
[Música]
pero para los 4.000 periodistas
presentes Kan ocurre sobre todo en el
Palacio del festival tenemos la suerte
de descubrir los largometrajes en
preestrena y en condiciones
excepcionales más de 60 películas se
proyectarán de aquí al 27 de mayo
sin duda la subida de las escaleras de
Kan por el elenco cinco estrellas de la
nueva película de West Anderson será un
momento memorable de la segunda semana
del festival tomé
por solo nombrar algunos Nos despedimos
entonces con las imágenes de asteroides
City Gracias a ustedes por su confianza
y sigan con nosotros hay más cultura en
24 y 24 punto com
[Música]
con sopas